so for the reasons given in the
judgments we have today handed down
this appeal
will be dismissed
and what i propose to do now is to read
out a
summary of the judgment a short summary
so as to explain to the press and to the
public
what we have decided
it should be noted however that this
summary forms no part of our decision
but it's just provided for information
and the better understanding of the
decision
the the central question
in the case
was whether the judge then mr justice
warby now
lord justice warby had been right
to grant summary judgment for breach of
privacy
and breach of copyright
to megan duchess of sussex
against the publishers of the mail on
sunday newspaper and mail online
associated newspapers limited
the claims related to the publication in
the mail on sunday and the mail online
i'll call them together mail on sunday
of about half the contents of a
five-page
hand-written letter which i'll call the
letter
which the duchess had sent on the 27th
of august 2018 to her father
mr thomas markle
the court of appeal
upheld the judge's decision
that the duchess had a reasonable
expectation of privacy in the contents
of the letter
and those contents were personal
private
and not matters of legitimate public
interest
the articles in the mail on sunday
interfered with the duchess's reasonable
expectation of privacy
and were not a justified or
proportionate means of correcting
inaccuracies about the letter
that had been contained in an article
published on the 6th of february
2019
in people magazine in the united states
the key point
was that the mail on sunday articles
focused on revealing the contents of the
letter
rather than providing mr markle's
response
to the attack on him
in the people in people magazine
the headline
was revealed
the letter showing
true tragedy of megan's rift with a
father she says has broken her heart
into a million pieces
and the first line of the mail on sunday
article read
the full content of a sensational letter
written by the duchess to her estranged
father
shortly after her wedding
can be revealed for the first time today
those passages demonstrated that the
mail on sunday articles were splashed
as a new public revelation
of extracts from the dutchesses letter
to her father
rather than her father's answers to what
people magazine had written
associated newspapers argued that the
judge had failed
to realize how people magazine had
produced mr markle
by alleging that he had cold-shouldered
his daughter at the time of the wedding
lied about her shutting him out
and ignored her pleas for reconciliation
in a loving letter
the court of appeal found
that the judge had been right to decide
that just one paragraph of the letter
could have been justifiably deployed
to rebut the allegation in people
magazine that the duchess's letter was
loving
when in fact it was not it was a letter
reprimanding mr markle for talking to
the press
and asking him to stop doing so
the court of appeal rejected associated
newspapers arguments that the judge had
firstly applied the wrong legal test
in deciding where the balance lay
between the duchesses article 8 writes
in
the letter
and the rights of mr markle and
associated newspapers to freedom of
speech under article 10.
also the court of appeal rejected
associated newspapers arguments
that the judge had failed properly to
evaluate
associated newspapers defenses to the
duchess's breach of copyright claim
first fair dealing in reporting current
events
and secondly the public interest in
reporting the letter
it had been common ground that the judge
had correctly stated the legal
principles that were applicable
to the question of whether summary
judgment should be granted
the court of appeal commented that the
new evidence that had been provided to
it
had also been widely publicized in the
press nationally and internationally
and in those circumstances the court
decided that the new evidence should be
admitted
as a matter of pure pragmatism
even though
it was more directed to the drafting of
the letter
and to what the duchess knew about the
contacts between
the kensington palace communications
team
and the authors of a book finding
freedom
than to the issues in the appeal
despite actually finding the evidence
the new evidence of little assistance
the court of appeal noted that the
duchess had apologized to the court
for the pleading served on her behalf
that said she did not know if and to
what extent
the communications team were involved in
providing information for the book
it it had appeared from new evidence
from mr canal
that he had provided some information to
the authors of the book
with the duchess's knowledge
the court of appeals said that this was
at best
an unfortunate lapse of memory on her
part but did not bear on the issues and
had been given no prominence in
associated newspapers oral argument
so for the detailed reasons given in my
judgment
the judge's careful decision mostly on
factual questions was upheld
and it was hard to see what evidence
could have been induced at trial that
would have altered that situation
the judge had been
we found in as good a position
as any trial judge
to look at the article in people
magazine
the letter itself and the mail on sunday
articles
to decide if publication of the contents
of the letter
was appropriate to rebut the allegations
made against mr markle
the judge had correctly decided
that whilst it might have been
proportionate to publish a very small
part of the letter for that purpose it
was not necessary to publish half the
contents
of the five-page letter as associated
newspapers had done
the court reiterated in conclusion
the narrowness of the issues
that it had had to decide
so that concludes the summary
um all consequential matters will be
dealt with in writing
um after today in the usual way
uh unless council have any submissions
they'd like to make about that
um that concludes this short hearing
no submissions from me milo or for me
thank you mr caldwell
all right
you